tracy mccrary is a senior sergeant at
the bay view police station in san
francisco she joins us tonight
sergeant i i i'm amazed that you're
willing to come on the show and grateful
that you are thank you very much tell us
what it's like in san francisco right
now
well thank you for having me
san francisco as you can see from all
the videos the boarded up shops the
empty spaces for retail is a city that
is spiraling or already in the bottom of
the toilet so
what's going to happen
i mean can it get worse
anything is possible
okay again
thank you for your first
account of this we watch the videos but
you know if you don't live there it's
hard to know you're a police officer
there how frustrating is this for you to
watch
well for me it's very frustrating
because i'm a native here born and
raised
the time i did spend in the bayview
before i was promoted to the lieutenant
who's now in charge of the robbery unit
which is my day job
i see all of this in real time and it's
concerning i see this when i'm working i
see this when i'm off duty i see this as
the vice president of the union
representing the men and women trying to
serve this city to the best of their
ability
i don't know about our other partners
what they're doing but we have a problem
let's recognize that we have a problem
and let's get to a solution
are you confident the police could fix
this if they were allowed to fix it
yes i am i am very confident because we
have the will of 2200 members who come
in day in and day out to do their job
and to make this city better
amen and that's the whole that's the
whole point of government is to make the
lives of the people who live in your
city better i gotta ask what percentage
of the population people who live in san
francisco
are frustrated by this
well i'll say a lot now
you mentioned
the d.a the recall that is happening you
had 83 000 signatures they want to blame
the republicans we don't have 83 000
republicans in san francisco so it's a
cross
no we don't so it's a cross-section of
people who are now fed up the west
portal area just had a sideshow
which has set people off
so
like we know what we need to do
let's just have the guts to do it and
stop talking about it you know so it's
incredibly frustrating but even as
frustrated as we are we're still willing
to show up and to do our job and i wish
our other partners in the justice system
would just do theirs
well you've certainly done yours tonight
teresa mccrary of the san francisco
police department grateful that you came
on tonight i hope that makes a
difference i bet it will thank you
i hope so too thank you